obviously you don't get an opening  advantage usually with the first bullet  but you still  open different playing fields and put  stress on them and then you have you can  choose according to all the match goes  where you want to keep going  i think basically well  our strategy is that we think  are we sure magnus is the better chess  player so he was trying to  get them to play positions and both are  out of prep is fine for us it's almost  better than if both of them are in prep  i would say right and  i mean i don't know if you can say our  openings was less ambitious than earlier  but they were more trying to get  playable positions